hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
zieht vorstellung heute trage ich den
den skin von fett sakko saurier und der
zieht ist von ferdinand flux viel spaß
heute wurde mails zugesendet von
ferdinand flux wir gerade schon gehört
habt ich habe das schon als eingetippt
klicke einfach nur auf dem moor world
options um dann seht ihr auch schon
wieder sieht ist und zwar 78 74 61 22 31
8 63 65 41 10 also leicht zu merken auf
jeden fall dass hier lass dir einfach
alles auf den normalen sachen dann würde
ich sagen creation wir uns die neue welt
die ich auch schon vorhin gesagt habe
habe ich heute denen es gehen von fett
sakko saurier an so sieht er aus also
ordentlicher ganz viele kühe rottweil
ist neben ganz vielen kühen also er
jetzt bond im flachland war echt eine
menge tiere sind da ja genau da hinten
sind noch scharfe wander grad ein
da ist ein braunes schafften ein meisten
scharf da ist eine coole dirt blog also
ganz interessant da hinten sind auch
noch irgendwo schweine und zwar hier
sport da und dann habt ihr hier erstmal
eine fette schlucht und zwei meinte
ferdinand flux dass in den cee'd planes
beim tempel mannschaft schlucht und ein
dorf mit einem schmied s und ich zeige
euch leichter ist nicht nur ein dorf
naja hier habt ihr erst mal eine kleine
schlucht also direkt beim spawn so ihr
könnt euch noch daran erinnern dass hier
der sport war einfach immer die ganzen
zu ganzen kühnen darüber gucken dann
seht ihr schon dass der despot ist dann
finden wir hier einen moment da ist er
hier ist ein tempel da sind eigentlich
gar nicht so tolle sachen drin die sind
eigentlich total kacke nein die sind
eigentlich sogar extrem geil und zwar
gehen wir mal ganz kurz da rein
es ist natürlich jetzt blöd dass hier
ein bisschen dunkel ist haha heute nicht
du heute mache ich das hier
hh und zwar sind hier drei goldbarren
ein diamant und neuen knochen drin also
auf jeden fall schon mal ganz cool für
den staat wenn man da direkt zum tempel
geht hat man erstmal diamante aber kein
holz das ist ganz gut
also da war die schlucht da war der
winter da war der dschungel tempel dabei
ungefähr der spawn wenn man hier ein
wenig rüber fliegt kann man die fans
wieder wegschmeißen ihm er da unten ist
irgendwo ein höhlensystem das hört man
auch gleich wenn man in der schmiede
steht hat man nämlich ganz ganz viele
skelette und zwar ist hier ein wüsten
dorf ein extrem großes westendorf ich
gehe einfach mal kurz in die schmiede
rein da sind auch ein paar coole sachen
drin und zwar sieben obsidian zwei äpfel
und eine eigene jazz play das tue ich
erst mal auf den skin von dem fed
saxonia drauf focus on skin sie so viel
besser aus viel spaß also hier hat man
so ein interessantes dorf hier sind
überall so ein paar holz ließ wo man
group jetzt hab ich hier entschuldigung
hat ihn niemand gesehen
hier sind halt ein paar interessante
sachen ihr könnt euch ein bisschen was
zu futtern darf wegholen oder könnten
mit diesen komischen tadeusz nasen typen
da handeln
naja also hier hat man dann das baby
schon vorhin gesagt hab hier rechts mit
dschungel biom und hier links das
flachland gebirge jetzt müssen noch ein
kleines stück schon fliegen pflegen
pflegen verlegen und zwar meinte
ferdinand flux unter anderem das heute
nicht aufgeschrieben aber der ganz
hinten das habe ich gesehen als noch ein
bisschen rum geflogen bin und noch ein
paar andere sachen zu entdecken
kakaobohnen dass da hinten auch noch ein
dass enten noch ein dorf ist noch ein
kleines dorf kann das eigentlich nicht
nennen so ein kleines café und ganz
kleines ganz ganz ganz ganz einfach nur
karten schlaf gestorben
naja egal hier war irgendwo noch ein duo
auf moment ich finde dass da müsste es
eigentlich gleich kommen gleich kommt
gleich kommt es da und was er auch
meinte dass irgendwo noch ein
minenschacht ist auch so im spawn
gebirge das habe ich aber nicht gefunden
von daher sucht einfach mal den setup
der eingeblendete jetzt einfach so ein
kleines dorf quasi am strand könnt ihr
euch will wenn wir schon mal ganz
interessant wenn man sich einfach mal
hin baut hier zum dorf aber das ist halt
blöd weil hier sind gar keine alters-
und halt wirklich nur ein paar leute mit
dem handeln kann was macht ihr hier so
gut das war der sieg von ferdinand
flugsicherheit den skin von baku saurier
die immer wenn ihr irgendwelche sie
zwist oder wenn ihr wollt dass meuren
skin in der nächsten folge anziehe dann
schreibt mir euren skin oder
ein sieht in die kommentare wird mich
auf jeden fall freuen und bitte vergesst
nicht das video zu bewerten ich würde
mich über einen daumen hoch freuen
oder wenn es nicht so gut fanden mit
einem daumen runter dann würde ich sagen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal